so Harrison Brian congratulations on the
film all I will say is that your
performances just left me breathless it
was beautiful yeah I wanted to ask you
Ryan cuz I just talked to Denny and he
basically intimated when you first sat
down to talk about the script that you
looked at each other laughed and were
like there's no way we're gonna touch
this masterpiece so can you talk about
that meeting and how well two Canadians
know this we were both in a state of
shock that we were even having the
conversation but you know he has said
incredible you know he what was amazing
was that he was such a fan of the
original that it was one of the seminal
films for him made him want to become a
filmmaker and he had such a reverence
for it at the same time he wasn't
intimidated by this he he felt like he
you know it was clear that he had a
clear vision for it and he it seemed
like he felt he had an obligation to
that and so it was he was an easy guy to
follow I think he met it too I was just
gonna say I really feel like if you're
trying to touch the Stars you guys
definitely at least got to the moon it's
really great so I loved it and then
Harrison for you I feel like over the
years there had to been tons of scripts
that were sent to you where somebody
thought that they could do this
continuation or a reboot or whatever how
many took nothing no no I don't think
anybody would have dared really those I
certainly over the years got scripts
that that that took a lot from the world
Blade Runner and
but I mean it took Ridley had been
working on this idea the ideas the
potential ideas for another Blade Runner
story from for a long long time and he
called me about four years before we
started shooting and said
theoretically are you would you be
interested in coming back and I just
read an interview the other day which he
claims I said how but I said well you
know do you have a story what are we
talking about and he sent me a novella
that he'd written as a kind of
foundational exercise for the writing of
the script and it had had the level of
complication and reference to the to the
to the original film that and ik and a
path for my character that was very
compelling and I thought real worthy of
my path worth following and then he
brought all these fantastic people
together Ryan not Brad and Danny Roger
Deakins all the other actors a wonderful
wonderful group of people to work with
Thanks okay real quick last question
sure I guess there was a film that you
saw Bryan's where he said that was the
one where you felt he could be the guy
to do this what film was it which
performance I guess he saw him in
something and you're like you're early
on thinking that he would be a good
person play the role not any one role
just you know watching the progress of
his career the the
indelible characters that he created the
respect he had for the process his
investment and then reading this role I
thought and I'd wanted to work with him
before that's the guy and they when I
told with great enthusiasm the producers
I had a really good idea there wouldn't
it be great if we could get Brian or
Brian we know we've been working on
anything congratulations thank you
beautiful I know that you said that you
wanted to do this film specifically
because you loved the first one so much
you felt you had to can you talk about
how you kind of compartmentalized the
fandom or did you lean into it and
making the film like how did you keep
your fan in check the the the fan when
you read the screenplay said to itself
himself
alright there's a strong screenplay
there so they will make the movie and I
don't want somebody has to [ __ ] it up
so and then I I left the fan at home I
didn't want to do this movie with
nostalgia I didn't want to make the
movie like someone with an eye I loved
the first movie so much but I didn't
want the two blind at me I needed to
find my own freedom to find my own voice
in that universe and for that for the
better better order worse stuff I mean
it's like I didn't know what my chances
of success were super small I mean it's
like so I am I needed that freedom that
freedom here to make it be able to
evolve in this way I love that you say
that because I feel like a director of
your caliber to say that your chances of
success are small I'm just like if
even at a tenth of UK I'd feel like my
chances were huge
Ryan Gosling and I we one of our very
first meeting we looked at each other in
the eyes and we start to laugh and say
okay we're doomed
it's like it's impossible it's like it's
like we know that we both I'm talking
for for Ryan but I feel okay about that
because it's something we shared as a we
made peace with the idea that we were
that we were going with a very strong
car full speed toward the wall and and
we had the chances to to go to the
little tiny hole in the world and to
survive as I was very very small chances
is it's like because no matter how good
our movie will be it will be compared to
a masterpiece so you're you know okay
and I and knew that people everybody
were rightfully very nervous about this
idea of making a sequel
some people were excited other people
thought it was a bad idea
and I was among both gangs and I was
having both feet and I was like so it
took so once you accept that you accept
that you cannot expect anything from the
result you have to just enjoy the
process do this as a pure artistic
gesture just for the pure joy of making
cinema and being inspired one by one of
the best movie of all time then you you
find your freedom and and you were
you're able to work and the other thing
I was just gonna ask you to is you
talked about Harrison and Ryan and them
doing this together obviously you had to
have that moment though to where like
I'm directing Rick Deckard like so was
there that moment where you kind of let
it come out a little bit when I when him
and Ryan were going at it by the thing
is that
it was for me frightening that was one
of the biggest challenge during this
movie was to bring back that character
that very iconic character that
everybody remembers and it's like I
needed I really needed Arizona I would
have never been able to do it alone and
but yes the truth is that the first day
as a director you Derrick Harrison Ford
which was like one of my childhood
heroes you know it's like I was like
pinching myself I had to breathe a
little and say okay okay let's be
professional here I'm supposed to direct
him you know but it's like it's I'm not
intimidated very often by actors but for
arason I I'm grateful because he really
broke the ice and and we met before and
he's a very warm thoughtful generous
humble man at the same time is I receive
or well no it was like a impressive for
me to work with Harrison I'm still
waking up something I can I can't
believe it happened